what's up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu i'm your host warren
thompson and we finally have some good
news concerning thor love and thunder
both the movie and the official teaser
trailer the last time that we talked
about thor love and thunder it wasn't
looking so good because they had decided
to do some reshoots obviously this would
push the release of a teaser trailer
back if they needed footage to use for
the teaser trailer and it was looking
like the movie itself might actually get
delayed if they didn't get everything
they needed in time however today we
have some good news it's looking like
the movie is not going to get delayed
and it's looking like the trailer is
going to be coming soon as we have an
official update today from chris
hemsworth thor himself so let's break it
down and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so today on
instagram chris hemsworth posted a
picture of him tessa thompson and tycho
watiti making an announcement in the
post he said some long lead press for
thor love and thunder with these two
wonderful humans a day full of wackiness
and hilarity get ready folks this film's
gonna be wild so chris hemsworth
announces that the thor love and thunder
official press tour has begun and this
is really good news for two different
reasons one is this probably means that
the movie isn't going to be getting
delayed since they're going on tour
right now and they're talking about the
movie they're going to be talking about
the official release date and it's a big
commitment to do the press tour you're
on the road basically all of the time so
it looks like they're done doing
reshoots and probably won't be doing any
more since most of their time is now
going to be focused on the press tour so
it looks like thor love and thunder
isn't getting delayed which is awesome
news but also at the same time this
probably means that the trailer the very
first teaser trailer is going to be
coming pretty soon it definitely seems
like thor love and thunder and marvel
studios is ready to start fully
promoting this film since they're going
on tour and since they're going on tour
it would make sense that the trailer 4
thor love thunder would be released soon
so the press could actually ask them
questions relating to the movie based
off of the info given to them by the
teaser trailer because there's only so
much you can ask about a movie without
really knowing anything about it and not
to mention you don't want to give any
spoilers away so the trailer allows the
press to ask specific questions
pertaining to the trailer that aren't
exactly too spoilery so it just makes
sense that they would release the
trailer pretty soon plus not to mention
promotion for thor love and thunder has
been ramped up quite a bit lately
they've released official toys and lego
sets for the movie we've seen decorative
ornaments for this holiday season
already go on sale that have given us
new looks at the characters and of
course there has been official promo art
for thor love and thunder that has gone
out as well so really the only thing
kind of missing at this point right now
is that very first teaser trailer which
looks like is going to be coming pretty
soon since the press tour is just now
kicking off it could even come as early
as this week now i don't think they
would do it wednesday because that's
when moon night airs but i would say any
other day is up for grabs if not this
week i would probably say we're looking
at next week either way it should be
coming very very soon and if i hear
anything at all of course i'll be sure
to do an update video in the meantime
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest thor love and thunder news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]